did you click on this video to finally
learn how boba fett escaped from the
belly of the sarlacc well you're in luck
here's what went down in the first
episode of the book of boba fett star
wars fans have been eager to learn more
about boba fett ever since he first
appeared in 1978's star wars holiday
special in 1980 star wars episode 5 the
empire strikes back although he was
originally played by jeremy bullock in
live action temuera morrison stepped
into the role for the mandalorian season
2 after playing bobo's father jango fett
in star wars episode 2 attack of the
clones boba is an exact clone of django
so morrison's return fits perfectly but
many fans have wondered whether the book
of boba fett will reveal some
jaw-dropping secrets about the star wars
universe this is mainly because the
first live-action series the mandalorian
changed the face of the franchise
forever by introducing baby yoda aka
grogu although the new series widens the
universe it doesn't pull the rug out
from under the audience star wars fans
will be glad to know that the series
wastes no time in answering one of the
biggest questions surrounding the
legendary bounty hunter it starts with
boba waking up inside the sarlacc after
the action-packed opening to star wars
episode vi return of the jedi his escape
from the literal belly of the beast has
previously been explained in books and
comics but it's exciting to see it in
live action it's only a brief sequence
as he uses a dead stormtrooper's oxygen
to stay alive before punching a hole in
sarlacc stomach and setting the monster
a flame this is a man who just refuses
to die but from there his escape isn't
so easy the episode uses boba's time in
the back to tank to flash back into his
past filling in the gaps between return
of the jedi and his reappearance in the
mandalorian once boba makes it out of
his trial by sarlacc he passes out from
the entire ordeal unfortunately he's set
upon by a band of jawas who quickly
steal his armor from him while he's on
ground this immediately ties into the
mandalorian chapter 9 wherein din jaren
comes across cop bam he's the marshal of
most pelgo who buys boba's armor and
rocket pack from the jawas to protect
the small town from gangsters as well as
the behemoth crate dragon if being
mugged by jawas isn't enough boba is
also set upon by tuscan raiders who tie
him up and take him back to their camp
luckily he isn't tortured the way
anakin's mom is during attack of the
clones but they do tie him up with a
captured rodian as a massive keeps watch
obviously boba isn't the type to stay
put when he's captured and quickly makes
us escape into the desert although he's
pursued by the tuscans they're extremely
vicious as boba finds out when he's
forced to fight one of them
interestingly his opponent uses a gappy
stick similar to the one boba wields in
the mandalorian he's definitely going to
become an honorary sand person although
they're not on friendly terms just yet
and he loses the fight
the flashback sequence is over once
fenix shand wakes boba up out of his
back to nap and it's time to get to the
bulk of the story there's a power vacuum
left on tatooine following jabba the
hutt's death and return of the jedi and
clearly boba feels he's the one to fill
it but it's going to take more than the
bounty hunter saying he's the new crime
lord for him to establish rule even when
the respective crime factions start
bringing tributes to vet the mayor of
mos espa doesn't even show up instead
sending his twilight major domo to ask
for a tribute from boba that's not a
good sign but still the bounty hunter
turned crime lord is determined to turn
over a new leaf intending to rule with
respect instead of embracing jabba's
iron-fisted approach so this therian
major domo manages to leave with his
life it's a bizarre change for the
bounty hunter who has long been fueled
by revenge and rage although clearly
there's more to this plot point at least
some of the planet's authority figures
bowed to boba
would you like your gomorian's hose down
and fed while we are sequestered
notably a twilight known as madame garza
fills his helmet with credits she runs a
bar called sanctuary and it looks a lot
cleaner than the most eisley cantina
this juxtaposition between boba and
jabba's rule critically sets the stakes
for the rest of the series while some
denizens of the desert underworld like
garso will likely embrace boba's new
regime others will summarily reject it
years of toiling under the murderous
huts has likely led many factions on
tatooine to view boba's more reasonable
style as a sign of weakness a weakness
they are likely to exploit
sure boba might be one of the most
feared bounty hunters in the entire
galaxy but tuscan raiders simply don't
care they'll turn anyone into a slave
pets in the unnamed rhodian are forced
to wander through the desert with a
tuscan youngling and they come across a
band of looters raiding a random
moisture farm they don't intervene
simply watching from afar expect boba to
encounter the gang later in the series
from there the tuscan young lean forces
boba and the rodian to dig up black
melons from under the sand unfortunately
the rodian uncovers a giant six-limbed
behemoth which can only be described as
a lizard centaur thanks to the way it
runs with its torso facing upwards
luckily boba uses his chains to strangle
a giant beast to death in the same way
princess leia kills jabba the hutt in
return of the jedi since he saves the
tuscan youngling the episode ends with
the sand people accepting fett as the
leader hands him a melon to drink from
on their return
his alliance with the tuscans is
probably how the bounty hunter survives
on tatooine for so long without his
armor in his signature spaceship but
we'll probably learn more whenever boba
takes it back to nap in future episodes
by the end of chapter one we may not
have seen the rumored return of emilia
clarke's kira or live-action darth maul
but both seem even more plausible in
future chapters thanks to the inclusion
of a very telling musical cue in the
book of boba fett
discerning fans will note the deliberate
deployment of a tune associated with the
criminal organization crimson dawn aka
daenerys targaryen side hustle after
solo underperformed at the box office
fans feared we might never get a
satisfying resolution to kira's
storyline nor any real payoff from the
big reveal that a revenant dark maul was
still kicking around managing organized
crime thanks to these key musical
phrases it seems incredibly likely we'll
get satisfaction as it pertains to one
or both of these questions the book of
boba fetts may essentially be solo 2
which is actually great because it means
we don't have to watch solo 2.
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the book of boba fetts are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]